[Music]
hey you guys the book that i'm reviewing
this week i mean
if you looked at the title
you already probably know why i picked
this one what actually ended up
happening was that i've been reading a
lot of stuff on my kindle unlimited so
all of these that i'm have been doing
like the last few weeks and the ones
that i'm probably going to be doing in
the foreseeable future are ebooks so i'm
not going to have them to hold up which
kind of sucks but whatever i'll just
like put them up here somewhere in the
video
so i had actually started reading a
different book to do for this show
and i might get around to finishing that
one at some point too because it was an
author that someone had recommended to
me but i kind of never read the author
before and i kind of i'm not going to
say who it is but um but i started
reading it and it's just i got about
maybe a little less than halfway through
and i'm just like gosh this i'm just
really not like it's good but i'm just
really not getting into it and it just
kind of seemed like a slog and so i was
like well you know i still have time to
like pick another book and read it so i
was scrolling through the new horror
offerings that are available on kindle
unlimited and this little gem turned up
right here this actually came out back
in october of 2021 so it's fairly new
and this book this charming tome is
called man [ __ ] this house
and as soon as i saw that title and then
it was for free on kindle you know me i
was just like oh my god that looks like
i told tom about it and tom said that
sounds like something i would name a
book and i said that's probably why i
thought it was funny so uh so yeah so i
was like okay i have to read this so i
was like eve i was like even if it's not
that good just that title i love it so
much that i'm sure i'm gonna enjoy it
and i'm happy to report uh that this was
actually a ton of fun this book was
really really fun
so i don't want to spoil too much about
it because like i said it's pretty new
so the guy that wrote it uh brian asman
he's apparently um i don't know how many
he's written several books prior to this
and has been in a bunch of um a bunch of
anthologies usually like bizarro type of
fiction so i kind of feel like i haven't
read any of his other stuff like i said
but
other reviews of this book there aren't
that many because i guess because it
just came out
but other reviews of this book some
people said that this book was a little
bit different than what he would
normally do in the sense that i don't
know if they're if they meant that it
was kind of more normal than what he
would usually do because i've i thought
i mean i kind of thought that was like
the unspoken implication but i could be
totally wrong so like i said he's kind
of more known for doing quote-unquote
bizarro fiction this one has elements of
that but it's pretty straightforward
it's funny but i don't know i don't want
to say it's like not as funny as you
might be expecting like it's not goofy
um it is actually kind of a cool story
and it does have a lot of uh you know
kind of really cool elements to it it's
sort of like a haunted house story i
mean it is a haunted house story but
it goes in
uh some directions you maybe don't
expect uh which like i said that kind of
ties in with the whole bizarre thing
which i don't really want to spoil
because i went into this book only
knowing oh my god that's an awesome
title and i really like the cover as
well so it is and i didn't know anything
about it i didn't even read the synopsis
i was just like with that title how can
this be bad because and it's not it's
not it's actually it was actually quite
wonderful
so the setup of this
is that there's a family
the haskins family you got your dad hal
who's like your typical
dad he like sells reverse mortgages he's
kind of like dumpy he tells dad jokes
and makes sports metaphors and he's just
kind of like not a bad guy but he's not
a real exciting guy you know what i mean
so he has a wife named sabrina who
i guess when she was younger had some
sort of aspirations of sort of doing
something with her life but she's kind
of one of those women that
you know you just kind of like end up in
this place and she didn't she's not
unhappy but she didn't really mean to be
there so she ends up married to hal and
she's like
i love him maybe it's like i'm not she
doesn't really think all that much about
it she ended up having two kids she has
like a daughter and a son and ended up
being a homemaker which is something
that she didn't really expect so she's
sort of like dissatisfied with her life
like i said not unhappy but kind of feel
like she never lived up to her true
potential and that she kind of got
you know sort of maneuvered into these
situations without really you know she
doesn't didn't have a lot of ambition
and ended up somewhere she didn't expect
to
so they also have two kids michaela the
daughter who i think is 10 or 12. i
can't remember how old she was she's a
little bit older and then there's the
youngest son whose name is damien and
the reason that his name is damien
is because when sabrina had him i guess
like she wasn't expecting it and she
didn't really
uh jive with the kid right away
and her and this kid that's this is
actually one of the funniest things
about this book is that her and the kid
have a real
contentious relationship um
she just cannot bond with him at all but
a lot of it is because some of the
chapters are told from the kids point of
view from damien's point of view
damien is a kid he's still a kid but
he's kind of one of those really super
precocious children and he thinks
it's
funny and also kind of he's very very
superior
and he almost like thinks it's funny
that sabrina
is afraid of him so he plays up
um kind of this
like he'll do creepy [ __ ] on purpose
just to like get her goat you know what
i mean so it's like this really
fractious relationship between the two
of them and there's one scene like later
on where the dad even asks her outright
do you hate our son uh just because she
can't
you know she she can't really talk to
him she can't really relate to him
because the kid is
weird but like i said the kid's weird on
purpose like when they do when when his
internal monologue is going you can see
that he's just a very very intelligent
uh child but the fact that he he kind of
thinks everyone else is an idiot he's
one of those kind of like intelligent
even these even though he's only like
eight or ten or something so he's like
that but
he just finds it amusing that
his mother thinks that he's like a demon
child so he tries to like play that up
just to scare her so there's that kind
of whole thing going on too
so they lived in this one place and then
uh the dad how he gets a transfer to
this kind of small town
and they end up buying this house it's
like a cool like a nice little craftsman
or whatever which is actually much nicer
than their old house because hal got a
promotion
so as i said very standard setup so you
have kind of like this you know this
family dynamic which is really amusing i
actually really liked the dynamic
between it because the daughter who's a
little bit older than damian she's kind
of like his henchman in a way you know
what i mean like she's the only
she's the only one in the family that
knows what the kid is actually like that
he's not really a hellspawn that he's
like actually a pretty normal kid just
like really intelligent but so she just
like goes along with all these pranks
that he's playing although it gets to a
point where he's like doing some pranks
and she's like yeah i'm not down with
that anymore but for a while they're
kind of like henchmen
so they move into this house um sabrina
like i said is kind of a stay-at-home
parent and she's kind of having a hard
time adjusting
she really likes the new house like it's
her dream house but you do get a sense
too that she's kind of maybe settling
like you know well this is better than
where we were and you know maybe
everything will change here maybe
something exciting will happen and [ __ ]
like that and oh yeah something exciting
certainly happens now as i said it kind
of starts out like she meets the
neighbor they have this woman that lives
across the street whose name is zephyr
and she's like your typical like aging
hippie type of woman uh she kind of
plays into the story later on but that's
a good some good characterization as
well but uh yeah so a lot of stuff
happens where sabrina is kind of at the
house alone because her kids start
school um her car is being shipped from
wherever they were before and it's like
a long distance it's like six states or
something and she's having her car
shipped but it's not there yet so her
husband is at work so she's kind of at
home you know in the house all day and
she's kind of trying to like clean it up
and make it all nice for them and
everything like that
and then um a very very weird thing
happens while she's
unpacking their stuff
she sees this dude and this is like a
week or so like after the movers have
already left and she's kind of like at
the house alone and she's unpacking
she sees this dude
walk downstairs into the basement with a
with one of their boxes and say hey
where do you want this and she's like
what who are you and then she's like
over there and then he puts it over
there and then he like he kind of
vanishes into this crawl space that
there's really no way that he could fit
into
and she's kind of like looking they're
going what the [ __ ] did i just see so
it's like this wigs her the [ __ ] out as
it would
now interestingly like i said i don't
want to spoil too much about this
because it's really good to go into it
not really knowing where it's going
uh there is some ambiguity over
what
is what she's seeing really what's going
on or is she losing it because for a
long time her family thinks she's losing
it which like i said that's pretty
common for haunted house stories but
this story has a lot of elements to it
that are
that are kind of unique for like a
haunted house story even though the
structure of it is kind of like a
traditional haunted house story but the
characterization and the directions that
it goes in
kind of really make this one a very very
fun experience interestingly and one
thing and i will say this even it's not
entirely a spoiler
but
the things that she sees in the house
you know how most haunted house stories
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] starts happening in
the house
and but it's usually like malevolent or
even if it doesn't start malevolent it's
kind of like scary now this is kind of
scary too but
all of the stuff that happens initially
is stuff that
is helpful to sabrina in particular you
know what i mean it's kind of stuff like
like i said she sees a dude that's just
like carrying her boxes that was too
heavy for her to carry or she'll think
about taking a bath and she'll go up in
a really nice warm bath that's been
drawn for her and stuff so it's kind of
like at first that the haunting is sort
of
catering to her whims
um and that's kind of as far as i want
to take it because when i got to that
point i'm like whoo this is like an
interesting wrinkle because normally you
know normally haunted house stores like
they're doing they're either doing like
indifferent [ __ ] like you know closing
doors or whatever or they're doing some
stuff that's like actively malevolent
and this one starts out kind of
different to that and that was like
really intriguing because i was like
really interested to see where it would
go
so but like i said i don't this is a
very fairly new book and if you have
kindle unlimited you can read it for
free uh so i actually would recommend
that you go read this as apparently it's
not as
off the wall maybe as some of his
earlier stuff at least according to some
of the reviews i've read i don't know
because i haven't read them but this was
really i mean i'm really glad i picked
this one because i mean like i said i
thought that title is like so awesome
that it's like even if it's not that
good
um you know that's still i i still love
the title but
happily i had a great time with this and
honestly i think i read it
i think i might have read it in a single
sitting or maybe like a sitting and a
half or something like that i mean it
just it just flew by and i just had such
a great time with it it's just so fun
like all the characters are fun
especially that kid damien this like
kind of demon child i saw one reviewer
that said he kind of reminded her of
stewie like from family guy and yeah i
kind of i wasn't thinking that when i
read it but when when she brought it up
i was like yeah i see i see what you're
saying with that where he's kind of like
this super genius but
you know he's like real superior but
he's actually he is a good kid and he's
a real kid like at heart he's not like a
evil mastermind or anything but he is
like really precocious and
really superior and but he's a lot more
normal than he like lets on because it
amuses him you know for people to think
that he's evil or whatever but yeah so
please go on kindle unlimited or
actually it's probably better for the
author if you buy the
paperback uh because they have that
available too but if you have kindle
unlimited you really have no reason to
not go read this because it's super
super fun and it's gonna go in like a
bunch of directions that you don't
expect and uh it was just i i just had a
blast reading this one so yeah it's
called man [ __ ] this house
by brian asman please go read it it's so
amusing so that'll do it for this tomes
of terror and i will see you guys on the
next one bye